this class is the advanced class and
here we would probably like to drill a
little bit deeper than for example what
should I do against the exchange French
the water like the motivations for
picking up a specific line and one of
the let's say awkward lines that I have
is I'm a big d4 player I like to play d4
I find it easier to control the outcome
of the opening with d4 whereas with
efore I find that across the board
there's a wider berth if you will for
black so for example when I was growing
up as a kid it was like
efore was best by tests according to
Bobby Fischer and like just everybody
and I mean just everybody in those days
played ePHI it wasn't even close if you
look at the eCos the encyclopedia of
chess openings I think they're gosh they
could be up to Edition 5 but the e Co
the original ECE Edition number one for
efore g5 was by far by far the fattest
Edition I mean it was like man d4 c4
Knight f3 it had nothing next to the e4
e5 encyclopedia by the time we got out
to the late 1990s
efore c5 e co had expanded by about 300
pages it was sort of like the Sicilian
which is a kind of a flank opening if
you will just expand
did the ECE Oh enormous Lee let's go
back to d4 for a month so we go back to
d4 for a moment and well what flank move
can there be well we know there's the
groom fell the Kings Indian and of
course the Dutch that the Dutch never
literally from the time I 1970s till
today the time that I started chest the
Dutch never was really properly in
Dorset periodically people like Nigel
short Hikaru Nakamura maybe maybe a
Veselin Topalov even an Alexander
Shabalala played the Dutch but it never
really caught on so the e c.o never
really expanded in the touch so
essentially against D for the major move
of course is d5 the classical king queen
pawn after d5 c4 c6 the Slav the Slav
the Slav and the semi Slav became
everybody's favorite weapon like I mean
just like everybody just all the top
players from Garry Kasparov on down
started playing the Slav Kramnik so on
and so forth
everybody plays the Slav okay so in the
normal Slav the normal slips stop the
normal slob everybody plays takes on c4
a for Bishop f5 e3 and we have what we
might call the Slav position on the slob
then everybody just everybody started
playing the semi slob e7 e 6 and
massive massive expansion of the ECE oh
thanks to this position two major
branches Bishop g5 takes on c4 c4 b55
lead to what became known or is known as
the BOD Vinick pawn sacrifice that line
of play includes a 7h X pardon me Bishop
h4 g5 Knight takes pawn takes Bishop
takes Knight here g3 Bishop here bishop
here Queen here and we haven't even got
to the starting position yet I mean
there's just massive reams and reams of
games that happened here that is the
first branch first branch then we get to
what has become known as the Moscow
variation of the semi Slav and that goes
Bishop g5 nut takes on c4 bit h6 it was
this line of play for black that yeah
stop ah stop
efore that vishwanath on Anand in Bond
what was it mm
in 7 2007 bond 2007 this she won
essentially he won that World
Championship match with the black pieces
and this line so in the bought Vinick
pawn sacrifice Black Sox comprise the
pawns in this Moscow variation white
sacrifice upon massive massive increase
of the ec o encyclopedia of chess
openings thanks to this very very very
popular line of play d4 so what I wanted
to show is a move I think is very very
popular at the club levels and what I
thought or maybe I still think about it
I think is a proper antidote amateur
whoops
amateur players and professionals alike
we do like gambits we like gambits a lot
gambits are great fun they put pressure
on both the opponent the one we play the
player who's gamba ting the one who's
receiving the material and I've always
liked the Budapest the Budapest gambit
and I have seen it in amateur play for
my entire career
yeah and it's a very intriguing line
because it immediately challenges white
ok you know you've played c4 you played
d4 and you know black isn't supposed to
be able to play this move right I mean
hey that's a pond that's a pond that's a
pond so if white plays any move other
than taking the pawn on e5 he has no
chance for advantage for example a move
like d5 already I think Black has close
to a superior
aim after the move Bishop c5 I really
like blacks position here very much I
think this is an excellent Bishop on c5
and I think black is ready to play d7 D
6 and c7 c6 with a very good gig so
after ePHI essentially the only move is
takes new variation we're going to play
Knight here and we get this position now
one of the key supporters of you will of
the budapest gambit is a guy Peter
Svidler ok and Peters fiddler he was
playing a very very crucial game against
Vladimir Kramnik I think this was kind
of like a Soviet champion championship
game and Vladimir Kramnik
as white in this position and I think
that this position has been played
thousands of times in in in amateur play
play to move I've never considered with
white never considered this move at all
with white so we want to take a guess
that's a very reasonable move and it has
been played countless times
efore is a very standard mainline move
that wasn't f3 is a terrible move yeah
Queen d4 is a bad move pardon Queen what
No so what so the standard moves for
white White has played Knight c3 White
has played Knight f3 White has played
Bishop f4 this is considered the best
move by the way Bishop f4 White has
played efore with the idea after Knight
takes e5 to play f4 Knight back bishop
here there's a whole line of play that
goes from this position
Kramnik played a move really remarkable
move
I mean 93 what the heck is that I mean
that violates so many principles is not
even close and this is a top top Russian
championship game going on here what the
heck was the idea of night h3 simply put
as Peter Svidler himself explained one
of the great proponents again of the
Budapest it was that after here what he
felt was that White's plan is to put a
night here to put a night here and
eventually eventually to put a night on
this square and this was a really
undermining move of the Budapest let me
explain
against Knight f3 it is considered
proper by black to play Bishop c5
threatening the pawn on f2 provoking the
move III knight c6 Knight c3 Knight
takes e5 Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5
Bishop e2 ok so this is considered a
very very very standard line of play now
the most remarkable thing about this
line of play is how play proceeds from
here
White's Knight is one day going to come
to this d5 square so it's considered
normal for black the play moves like d6
and Bishop e6 and sometimes to capture
that night black might also pay some
attention to the move Knight e4 okay so
after this black comes up with the most
remarkable plan you've ever seen
a plan right out of my beginner days
what black plays is rook e8 b2 b3 this
move we absolutely absolutely understand
this Bishop on c1 is passively placed
behind the e3 pawn white conceives a
plan of putting his Bishop on b2 the
long diagonal once he plays Knight d5
this Bishop is beautiful black plays are
you ready for this a5 what Bishop b2
rookie six yes yes yes do you know the
name of Mahmud Arav Shaq
mommy Dara he just won the major
tournament in Beijing and he has played
numerous times this position with black
and what Shaq's idea is is we're just
going to go back a mover to and we're
going to ask a question of blacks
position you know it's like you know
chess is a team sport and when you play
in a professional league everybody gets
paid to play you know even if you're
riding the pine you get paid to just
ride the bench so in this position one
question that black has to ask himself
is what am I going to do with a bishop
what am I going to do with the rook what
am i doing with my queen so for example
if black conceives the play of d7 d6
very clever Bishop e6 excellent move
Queen d7 very good Bravo connecting the
rooks the rook comes to d8 and then and
then and then when you play the move d7
d6 you must be aware that the move
Knight a four will cost you your
to bishops yes when you've played all of
those moves I've just described the rook
on a eight really isn't earning its pay
it's not so now let's just see what
happens after the move a5 Bishop b2 rook
a six-night d5 rook h6 so what
mommy-daughter offs idea is is this rook
might look stupid
bad misplaced well I don't even know how
to describe it
but it is annoying it's far more
annoying for white than the rook on a
eight white is now observing that
there's potential of moves like Queen h4
if this pawn is ever provoked to the
square h3 this Bishop stands ready in
time with the move d7 d6 to sacrifice
itself ok stop and freeze that for a
second what has happened is there's been
a trade of knights okay anybody has
heard of Mark 2 varetsky marked of a
risky considered one of the world's
foremost trainers okay mark do varetsky
devotes entire chapters to his series of
training books to what he calls the
superfluous Knight
so the idea of the superfluous Knight is
simply that in certain types of
positions one player has a knight too
many this is one of those positions so
here what we're going to do is try to
understand the difference 9h 395 III now
when you play the move knight c6 very
normal move Knight f4 as Peter Svidler
experienced
the first part is notice that these
nights you truly protect one another
they in a sense a step on one another's
whose okay this night when it's been
traded for this night on be one as we
saw a moment ago in that variation where
black played a five rook here rook here
the rook got a chance to jump from a
eight to h6 thanks to the fact that this
Knight is now in the way there's no such
maneuver very very interesting so I just
point out Knight h3 I wrote an article
in inside chess magazine as an homage to
honor Bobby Fischer Bobby Fischer wrote
a bus to the Kings gambit do you
remember that article a bus to the Kings
gambit and he had this great line in his
article so he you know you know a win
after win after win after win after win
for black and then his conclusion that
the article was and if white plays
differently he loses differently so a
great line I just love that line so I
wrote a bust to the Budapest gambit with
the line and if black plays differently
he loses differently okay I think that
Bishop f4 is the best move and it's
certainly the most challenging maybe in
the 23rd century people will play moves
like Knight h3 and they'll be understood
as the best move into position
I'm still in the 20 21st century so I
don't understand ith look okay Bishop f4
the very very standard move is knight c6
black wants to win this pawn on e5 back
and I understand him Knight f3 Bishop b4
check considered the best move Knight c3
is standard Akiba Rubenstein the great
Akiva Rubenstein he preferred Knight BD
too because he was a very simple fellow
and he liked the two bishops this
actually happened in a tournament game
that I was a witness to it happened
right next to me queen e7 is the
standard move a two a three my friend
dr. David Leo staff RAC was on the white
side of I was on the black side of this
when this had been played and sure
enough white captured the bishop these
were expert players oh yeah haha yeah I
don't I think somebody lost rating
points but there was no revocation of
the title so this should be a pattern
that everybody knows iris do you know
what you would do you were black what
Jack writes mother checkmate this really
happened and I recall the the kind of
flourish that Leo gave to the move it
wasn't like okay of course
Akiba Rubinstein did not allow the
smothered mate then instead played the
movie three obviously his opponent would
take take castles Bishop e2 d6 and the
players would just play this position
modern grandmasters do appreciate the
two bishops but they don't think that
White's advantage is significant rather
quite miniscule here they don't think
this is an issue for the Budapest and I
tend to agree or rather put another way
I do agree Knight c3 this is the main
move and is featured in my bus to the
Kings gambit new mainland yes now here
there's a school of thought that says
what black has two moves he can choose
between queenie seven and Bishop takes
c3 I disagree black cannot play the move
Queen e7 in the first place if you play
the move Queen eise Evan you get a you
give white the option of a much much
better very variation of Rubinstein's
play it's the very same position as
before remember when I won the two
bishops but here the rook is actually
far more well placed on c3 then that
Queen was on d2 here obviously White has
an immediate killing threat Bishop takes
e5 in certain variations for example
like d7 d6 white could play the movie c5
with the move c5 white is trying to
create a target by making a weak pawn on
d6 obviously black had not take the pawn
because this wins okay so that's all
very clear so the move Queen East 7
gives white this option of rook c1 and
he shouldn't be given this option
queenie 7 also gives white a different
option and that is the move Queen b3
okay you cannot capture this pawn twice
because this bishop would then lack
protection black cannot capture this
night because then after Queen takes
this pawn is
hanging black cannot play the move
Bishop c5 because after e3 Knight takes
e5 Knight d5 is just not very nice okay
this is just a very very pleasant
position for the first play if you play
Knight here Knight a5 Queen c2 Knight
takes e4 in the words of nickel I'm
enough you will die with a full stomach
a3 Bishop here pawn here
Knight takes Knight d5 once again gets
you into a world of trouble this is not
what you want to do with black so in
this position after Bishop before check
Knight c3 don't play the move Queen e7
if you would want to play the gambit the
take first on c3 and now play Queen e7
now in the history there's been many
many many wonderful games from this
position in particular what was
particularly striking where the games of
svetozar gligar itch gligar itch pounded
the budapest
i mean i it was really really really
terrible what he did to the budapest and
glitter riches favorite move was the
move Queen d5 and he had a number of
victories just there sterling and you
know like just blood curling victories
in this line of play and for some reason
don't ask me why I mean they there was
like a line of customers that just lined
up to lose is black yeah yeah yeah lie I
next yeah
okay you know puncher ticket next you
know you're out of here and he was just
killing people so black players woke up
and they did not play Queen a3
they didn't go queen a3 rook here and
took this pawn instead
they accepted the gambit the the loss of
the pawn and played to move f7 si
sorry I wanted to emphasize that in this
position white has the strategical
threat of h3 driving this Knight to this
pathetic square playing efore and it's
over so f6 is basically oops that wasn't
right
f6 is basically only moved main move
takes Queen teh whoops wrong blunder
sorry Knight tags new main line now here
Gallade rich played a lot of different
moves but Queen d3 main line move d7 d
six and here glitch did some interesting
things with III Bishop e2 he would also
experiment with Knight d2 I played the
move g3 and I won numerous games with g3
so this is basically my bus to the
Budapest if at the club there are some
members who play the Budapest gambit you
can just nail them to a holy cross the
next time they play the glue to Fez guy
on it by playing g3 okay at this point
basically black is left with two moves
either he can play the move Knight e5
Knight takes D takes Bishop here and
have no compensation or he could play
the move castles most of my opponents
who have gotten into this position have
chosen the ladder castles Bishop g2 now
what's the big deal about g3 twofold
first and foremost with the move g3 I
protected the bishop that means that any
jumps by the knight discovered attacks
against the bishop well I've already got
that fellow covered that's point number
one
the second is that this bishop on
one wasn't any great shakes there was a
pawn on e 2 there's a pawn on c4 now
that bishop on g2 it's looking real good
I'm going to castle my king is going to
be safely tucked behind the bishop and
this Bishop on this long diagonal
eyeballing this pawn over here my
opponents have played the move Knight e4
against me yes I have castled and now
here unfortunately a few of them have
lost on the move they have played the
move Bishop f5 considering that their
position is really good and that they
were going to make a discovered attack
against my Queen and all sorts of bad
things were going to hit they were going
to do all sorts of bad things to me that
after the move Knight h4 is like it's
oopsy-daisy
Black is in bad bad bad bad shape
there's no really good discoverers
Knight takes g3 thank you very much I
taken the 9 the knight can't move
because Knight takes f5 is coming with a
tempo I am threatening Knight takes fi
Bishop b4 I think if I remember well
there I think my opponents have played
against me rook a8 and I have played
this cute little move c5 so in the first
place I'm getting rid of my double pawns
in the second place I'm setting up for
ideas like Queen d5 check I'm setting up
for ideas like okay D takes e5 take
steak steak steak stakes takes upon so
this position I have won routinely so
the best move in the position is this
move Knight see
the variation queen III okay so all of
these moves are basically forced this
whole line of play of the Budapest
gambit Bishop e6 trying to win this pawn
on c4 Knight d4 very nice Bishop takes
here Knight takes here Queen takes
Bishop takes all of these moves are
forced and we get to this ending this
whole line of play was all forced and I
have won this ending on several
occasions it's like the same ending the
same position it was just like this
whole series of moves and essentially
what we can see obviously is I'm getting
a four to two majority a three to two
majority for black but in the rook and
Bishop the dynamic play that black has
black usually plays forward these lines
of play rook there and rook there my
King side majority easily overwhelms
blacks Queen side so we usually have a
game that goes like this and you're are
you ready for it
turn your eyes small children don't look
don't look don't look black reasons rook
takes a to Rupp takes a to Bishop takes
a to rook here rook takes I can't take
the pawn with the rook I'll take the
pawn with the yes
and now ah yeah rook takes rook cake
yeah yeah and again I've won this ending
including just like this and my
opponents weren't experts either yeah
they didn't lose their titles I won't
tell you well titled they were but this
line of play against the budapest gambit
to my mind really puts the kibosh on the
budapest